est avec nous pour évoquer le pack c'est
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée Roseline Bachelot bonsoir
madame vous êtes député RPR et vous avez
une particularité dans ce débat c'est
que vous êtes le seul député
d'opposition qui est favorable à ce
texte alors est-ce qu'à votre avis ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui ça porte un
un coup au crédit du Pax ou pas je je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas parce qu'il y
a un véritable débat de fond qui
finalement n'a pas encore eu lieu et je
lisais un sondage qui est paru hier un
sondage BVA qui disait que 84 % des
jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont
favorables au Pax au pacte civil de
solidarité et jusqu'à 50 ans deux
Français sur TR sont favorables au Pax
donc de toute façon aujourd'hui demain
ou après-demain il y aura un texte qui
s'appellera pacte civil de solidarité
qui s'appellera comme il voudra mais qui
concrétisera ce besoin des Français cela
dit sur ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que les
socialistes ont fait preuve de
désinvolture ou de manque de cour
courage pour certains d'entre eux je
crois que si vous permettez cette
vulgarité Lionel Jospin sur ce sujet
s'est débrouillé comme un manche il a
d'abord refusé de faire un texte qui
soit d'origine gouvernementale il a donc
laissé sur un texte aussi important on
l'a vu à travers le débat de société qui
s'est déroulé il a laissé un texte
d'initiative parlementaire dans ce qu'on
appelle une niche c'est-à-dire un texte
qui ne se discute pas en milieu de
semaine mais qui se discute en fin de
semaine et encore heureusement qui avait
nos journées parlementaires sinon la
discussion aurait dû continuer le samedi
et le dimanche parce qu'il avait pas
beaucoup l'intention de se mouiller sur
ce texte alors les députés socialistes
ils ne se sont pas sentis mobilisés
parce que leur chef a agi avec beaucoup
de lâcheté et pas beaucoup de
détermination et maintenant il en
récolte les fruits et la droite la
droite est très mobilisée contre ce
texte mis à part vous donc est-ce que
vous pensez vraiment que que le Pax
menace la famille telle qu'on la conçoit
dans ce pays depuis plusieurs siècles
non je je je ne crois pas je crois qu'
qu'il y a eu est-ce qu'il y a est-ce
qu'il y AE est-ce qu'il y a lieu de se
réjouir de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui quand on est dans
l'opposition non je je crois pas qu'il y
a lieu de se réjouir ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre parce que finalement il y a
énormément de gens à l'intérieur de
l'opposition qui voteraiit bien ce texte
qui me l'ont dit qui m'ont dit oui il y
a des problèmes oui il faut trouver une
solution et qui s'y opposent parce qu'il
faut bien s'y opposer et puis de l'autre
côté il y a des députés socialistes ou
de la gauche plurielle qui ne sont pas
pas favorable au Pax et qui n'osent pas
l'avouer et qui ce soir ont voté un
petit peu par leur absence moi j'ai été
très frappé j'ai demandé qu'on me
communique la liste des maires de ma
circonscription qui avaiit voté vous
savez le fameux appel des maires contre
le pacte civil de solidarité j'ai
découvert avec stupéfaction qu'il y
avait des maires socialistes de ma de ma
circonscription qui avaient voté contre
le pacte civil de solidarité donc il
faut pas en faire de ce débat de société
un affrontement droite gauche quand nous
avons mis sur pied les lois très
importantes des lois de société qui
étaient l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ou qui était la contraception
on n'a pas dit aux députés de notre
majorité d'alors sur ce texte il faut
que vous votiez absolument tout le monde
pareil on veut voir qu'une tête on on a
laissé la liberté de penser parce que
c'était justement des textes de de de
société donc vous êtes en train de dire
finalement qu'il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie des deux côtés est-ce que
c'est parce que euh finalement ce texte
euh traite principalement de
l'homosexualité même si on l'a un petit
peu habillé depuis et que ça fait encore
un peu peur euh dans une certaine base
électorale ou il y a plusieurs c'est
vrai que le texte a été porté au départ
par des associations d'homosexuel et
puis on a on s'est bien rendu compte
tout au cours de ces années parce que
moi il y a pratiquement 10 ans que que
je m'occupe de ce dossier que finalement
des tas de personnes ont sont concerné
j'ai déposé leur du débat lors de la
préparation du texte un amendement sur
les frattereries pour que le texte
concerne les frères et sœurs qui vivent
ensemble j'ai reçu des dizaines de
lettres de gens me disaient me disant
mais oui on vit ensemble on est inquiet
on a besoin d'exprimer cette solidarité
entre nous donc c'est vrai un texte qui
parle d'une minorité mais dont
l'ensemble de la société saisit et
finalement c'est ça qui est important
sur ce sur ce sujet merci beaucoup
rosevine Bachelot